(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)
(uptempo music)
- Oh, darn!
- Do you have any crayons?
- [Voiceover] Oh, I'm sorry,
sweetie, we just ran out.
- Ugh!
- Daddy, can you play with me?
- [Voiceover] Um, yeah,
in just one minute, okay?
- Come on.
- Can I have a chocolate milk, please?
- [Voiceover] Uh, actually
let's make that a regular.
(girl sighs)
(boy laughs)
- Wait a minute.
- Mommy, the iPad's not working.
- [Voiceover] Oh, you know what?
You've probably had enough
screen time today, anyway.
- No, Mommy, I can fix it, I swear!
(adults murmur)
- Can we go now?
- [Voiceover] Hold on.
(adults murmur)
(girl sighs)
- [Voiceover] All right, Delilah,
two minutes and then we're gonna go.
- Okay.
- [Voiceover] Okay, you ready?
Let's go, time to go.
- What, that wasn't two minutes!
- How was your day?
- Don't ask.
(girl sighs)
(straw slurps)
(logo whooshes)
(hinge squeaks)